eu queria dividir com vocês duas
lembranças da infância
a primeira tem a ver com minha avó na
cidade onde ela morava com ela são paulo
todo final de semana com os meus pais
era frequente que a gente ia visitar
eu lembro nós morávamos em campinas a
uma hora de são paulo esse trajeto na
mira épico repleto de adultos com os
marginais praças abandonadas e poluição
e mais do que isso está repleta de
brigas
meus pais sempre brigavam por que a
gente se perdia achava o caminho à
cidade
ela parece infinita e mais do que
infinita ela aparecia também limitada
porque chegando à casa da minha avó
investir ali a casa era confinada né
existe realmente uma praça um lugar
próximo à casa dela onde a gente pudesse
se divertir
em paralelo a essa lembrança eu trago
comigo a lembrança do meu pai e das
nossas brincadeiras de família meu pai
tinha um sítio próximo de campinas ea
gente sonhava de construir nossa casa e
dentro dessa casa tinha todos os
desenhos da nossa família meu pai
desenho dessa sala que puder que podia
receber a luz do sol todas as horas do
dia
eu e minha irmã a gente sonhava em
quartos separados
a gente fazia os desenhos também de umas
casas labirínticas com fugas né que
podiam caminho de fuga para a cidade e
era enfim é e as construções e
imaginárias né dessa minha infância eu
levo comigo as duas perguntas saber se
um dia eu ainda vou poder construir essa
casa dos meus sonhos e se existe uma
cidade acolhedora integradora para
receber esses desejos mais tarde eu
cresci
eu não sei se por isso eu me formei em
arquitetura mas eu me dei conta que esse
desejo não era só meu
obviamente que é desejo de todos nós
todos nós temos a vontade de custos ea
nossa casa e mais do que um desejo
talvez eu me dei conta que são instinto
é um instinto animal que o ser humano
tem na verdade é que desde os primórdios
da humanidade né é um instinto de
sobrevivência o ser humano teve que se
juntar um grupo de pessoas escolheu um
lugar para viver
e juntos através de métodos construtivos
é construir as suas moradas e achar uma
economia sustentável de subsistência de
cozinha já em 1923 colocava que é grande
a arquitetura está nas próprias origens
da humanidade sendo ela o produto
imediato do instinto humano
muitas dessas construções primárias são
hoje exemplos de sustentabilidade né
mas essa sustentabilidade construtiva
nos seus métodos né que usa materiais
locais mas também uma sustentabilidade
social de um grupo de pessoas que se
conhece e que dentro de uma economia
própria consegue ter uma harmonia com o
seu entorno ea pergunta que eu me leva
hoje né esse é é se esses instintos de
que maneira esses instintos que se todo
mundo tem essa força que existe dentro
da gente
de que maneira essa força está sendo
usada na sociedade de hoje
hoje 84% da população brasileira vive em
cidades
esse no mundo é um pouco menor 54% a
sociedade industrial criou inovações
metrópoles sistemas viários e grandes
conjuntos habitacionais
a urbanista francesa françoise choay e
1955 já anunciado o fracasso das cidades
na sua capacidade de organizar os seus
espaços
desde que a frase foi anunciado ou desde
que as mesmas cidades o fenômeno das
cidades que crescem muito rápido
apareceu muita pesquisa foi feita em
dourados projetos pilotos prefeitos
sistema de gestões mas até hoje a
questão de acordar com a idade da cidade
existe e é um problema para todos nós
talvez simplesmente nós temos que
aceitar que nós perdemos a guerra frente
o crescimento desordenado das cidades e
se a gente perdeu essa guerra está vez
quer dizer que a gente não tem as boas
armas que a gente não tem isso usando os
bons métodos para lidar com a cidade
e aí me veio em mente né como é que esse
indivíduo está se integrando nessa
cidade o que você hoje
se você quer ter sua casa o que você tem
que fazer para conseguir ter a sua
própria casa
o caminho é fácil você tem que primeiro
estudar aprender a ler e escrever
trabalhar e ganhar dinheiro
e aí com isso talvez você vai conseguir
alugar comprar e eventualmente construir
sua casa
quantas dessas casas mesmos planejada
para aqueles poucos sortudos que
construiu seu construir as suas casas
tiveram uma relação de pensamento da
cidade
quantas dessas pessoas poderão ter um
envolvimento com a sua construção
eu eu quase diria que a cidade hoje já
são anônimas anônimas da nossa voz e dos
nossos desejos
lógico você vai dizer que existe favela
ainda bem que existe alguma maneira
porque de certo modo elas nos indica um
caminho e eventualmente soluções mas
nesse se enfrente essa questão talvez o
poder público não soube se organizar ou
talvez não tenha tido é a vontade né pra
ir mais longe porque o que aconteceu
aqui não foi possível dentro dessa dessa
vontade de cidadões que estavam pedindo
democracia e as essas casas né integrar
um sistema viário o sistema de rede de
saneamento e essa cidade nessa ela criou
uma maneira de um modo desorganizado
então por um lado a gente tem uma cidade
muda e de outro lado a gente tem uma
cidade desordenada e sem infraestrutura
básica
bom como é que a gente pode inserir
novamente esse indivíduo a produzir no
processo de produção das cidades longe
de ter a resposta eu cruzei na minha
experiência de arquitetura algumas
experiências que talvez me fizeram ver
um caminho né
primeiro eu acredito na minha prática
como profissional eu tenho um escritório
de arquitetura e logo nos meus primeiros
projetos
eu me coloquei essa questão como é que
eu ia me colocar com o desejo do meu
cliente
eu tenho a resposta eu devo eu é o meu
conhecimento técnico as minhas ideias é
formular uma solução é eu tô falando
aqui da questão de autoria e de como
essa troca feita entre uma pessoa que
teve talvez não seja toda sua vida eo
meu conhecimento técnico
vicente em cima dessa pessoa e do que
ela está querendo da sua vida
o que houve é que quanto mais eu abrir
esse diálogo e quanto mais eu fazia do
projeto um jogo aberto onde talvez
estabelecer algumas regras
mas aonde aquele futuro morador mexia os
peões e decidiram qual o caminho daquela
casa
mas essa pessoa vira a dona da sua casa
e se apropriava daquele espaço e mais
aquele projeto de alguma maneira tinha
uma sobrevivência maior em um sentido
maior na academia onde também o leciono
os alunos
eu nem junto com esse processo acadêmico
junto com os alunos é agir
a gente tem uma tendência a desenvolver
o projeto de maneira abstrata teórica a
maioria dos projetos trabalhados eles
são é longe do usuário da cidade onde
uma realidade qualquer o que a gente
ensina muito com os alunos é o da
narrativa de entender uma situação
construir um discurso e defendê lo na
verdade e nós tivemos então a
oportunidade né
dentro desse da academia de trabalhar
com um grupo de moradores da comunidade
do vidigal associação de moradores ela
veio entrou em contato comigo para fazer
um trabalho é existia uma necessidade os
moradores queriam trabalhar em excesso
de entrada da comunidade do vidigal e
queriam criar um quiosque literário um
lugar que pudesse representar um pouco a
comunidade acolher e também é dar novas
informações para esse projeto
nós montamos um grupo de alunos e
começamos a desenvolver uma série de
ferramentas do workshop processo fizemos
um processo participativo que foi levado
a voto que foi escolhido mas o que eu
pude ver nesse exercício é que muito
pouco do que a gente estava ensinando a
faculdade servir de ferramenta para
esses alunos e que eles tinham que
aprender metodologia uma metodologia de
projecto diferente mas discussão
participativas e um certo papel dentro
da sociedade que era diferente do que a
gente estava na academia
eu também tive a oportunidade de
trabalhar junto com a fundação bento
rubião na definição de um projeto de
moradias 500 casas construídas pelo
programa minha casa minha vida e esse
exercício foi é uma grande lição pra mim
porque
o que eu aprendi é que sim a gente pode
desenhar 500 casas dentro de um curto
espaço de tempo com a participação
social foram feitas em um período de
dois meses três meses dois workshops
três dias cada um de todos os moradores
foram chamados e nesses três dias de
workshops
a gente conseguiu trabalhar com os
moradores a questão do desenho das ruas
onde seriam localizadas as praças é
quais tipos de quadra eles queriam o
desenho dessas quadras quais tipos de
programas comunitários poderiam ser ali
inseridos e que tipo de apartamento de
moradia com essa especialidade que eles
alvejavam esse dados foram colhidos em
um projeto foi feito com isso então eu
aprendi aqui dentro de um processo
mercadológico sim a gente tem como
influir o indivíduo e mais do que isso
esse bairro nem existe mas vizinhos já
existem já se conhecem e se apropriaram
o território e suas casas
isso numa questão de durabilidade de uma
cidade não tem preço
é uma coisa que se constrói e quanto
mais cedo a gente pode construir maior
sucesso e acredito nos espaços
enfim eu queria é é assim todos esses
são exemplos particulares pequenos
exemplos e o que eu quero dizer é assim
a gente não consegue é eu não sei se
esses exemplos de pequena escala
representa alguma coisa realmente na
mudança das cidades
e aí eu me pergunto eu tentei fazer um
exercício não é pra entender o que eu
como é que a gente pode sair dessa
prática de projetos pilotos de ações
pontuais pra algo que possa ter um
impacto maior em uma escala maior
então tentei fazer um exercício inverso
eu tentei sair do que eu tivesse uma
oportunidade há quatro meses atrás de
mudar de casa e nessa mudança de casa
junto com as minhas filhas a gente
percebeu que que faltava um pouquinho né
pra poderem brincar próximo a minha casa
e eu me perguntei assim porque eu não
vou tentar fazer esse parquinho e aí eu
comecei a fazer as etapas na então vou
primeiro procurar meus vizinhos saber se
eles também querem um parquinho aí eu
fui à padaria foi no restaurante tem
achar as pessoas que eu conheci um
vizinho é conversei com um grupo de
pessoas ela
mas que também mostraram interesse nesse
primeiro exercício eu me dei conta que
se houvesse um sistema já organizado
estruturado uma vizinhança de bairro
como um condomínio aberto já seria uma
grande ajuda para as pessoas se
ponderarem porque elas podem fazer para
a cidade
no segundo momento é assim a gente
pensou se eles querem fazer o pac então
preciso talvez representar essa idéia é
fazer um folheto um croqui só pra dizer
que tem uma idéia é buscar abaixo
assinados e talvez na prefeitura
nesse momento o papel do arquiteto
também o arquiteto pode ser um
conciliador social e é importante já que
também se ponderarem dessa função e se
prepararem para isso
num terceiro momento pensei poxa onde é
que eu vou bater na porta da prefeitura
eu estou aqui teto até conheço um pouco
o caminho mas não existe hoje em dia um
sistema oficial que possa integrar os
desejos moradores da cidade não existe
uma cota um fundo que permita né a
pequenas ações urbanas não tô falando de
grandes coisas eu tenho certeza que cada
um de vocês é próximo a suas casas
é tem noção de pequenas coisas
diferentes que fariam diferença como um
banco ou uma harmonização das calçadas
certo tipo de visitação organizar os
carros como eles são alinhados ou não a
cidade precisa de grandes coisas mas
também de pequenas coisas para serem
melhores e se cada um de nós consegue
expressar isso a gente vai ter mais
força e mais qualidade nas cidades mas
eu acho que existe também o papel não só
de vocês todos vocês mas também do poder
público local as nossas legislações
urbanística são antigas
elas mesmo que existem instrumentos e
ferramentas nossas leis de qualidade a
realidade da aplicação urbana no brasil
ainda é muito falha então existe um
sistema que é mais antigo do que andré
do que isso assim é aí que precisa ser
renovado existe e isso não foi uma
grande reforma urbana mas tô falando de
pequenas modificações na maneira de
inserir o indivíduo no processo de
criação da cidade e vou poder assim uma
cidade como petrópolis que queira que
ter se pensando ela pode abrir portas
para essa mudança e acredito que juntos
poder público
nem é nós arquitetos e todos vocês
talvez a gente consiga melhorar as
cidades um dia espero assim